all right I I've been hyped up about
bromine over the past hour yeah what the
[ __ ] is bromine used for Nigel I don't
know I now I need to know so you want to
know what bromine used for besides
having fun yeah okay how much really uh
no it's
it's I think it's cool
because
that was the most obvious I think it's
cool uranium is kind of hype it's kind
of in right now
um no so it's like it's similar to
chlorine so if you smell bromine it's
like a weird chlorine oh does it
disinfect things yeah so in some in some
like uh it's common in hot tubs no yes
right I've heard about this and even
some Pools use bromine I feel like it's
more common in spas for whatever you see
the products that like Spa products is
it cheaper than chlorine
I don't I know they kind of I think
they've phased it out it was abandoned
in Canada or Quebec because I think it's
bromine is toxic slightly okay like
compared to chlorine I think there's
like some toxicity issue uh compared to
chlorine so we're trying to phase it out
of pools yeah and I think they stop
selling them as Pool Products but it's
if you look at the periodic table which
I'm sure you're very familiar
no no I I'm saying this a joke because
there are people who in chem aren't
familiar and I barely look at it I have
an engineering degree but I don't do it
I think it's like a meme that like
chemists look at the periodic table all
the time but it's kind of like
you I look up I look at it when I need
to and I don't remember half of it right
you don't have a poster of the periodic
table
it's right above my my office
every lab has the periodic table in the
new office it's like you only look at it
when you need to either way it's like if
you look at it Roman's in the family of
um halogens so it's like chlorine
bromine iodine and fluorine okay yeah
right so it's like it's between I don't
know I'm in my head I'm like oh God this
is all bad it looks it looks the same
color as iodine right kind of no so as
you go down let's look fluorine's at the
top okay and then it's a gas go down one
and you get to uh
um
yeah so it's like oh no but you get to
chlorine which is a gas yeah then you
get to bromine which is a liquid and
then below that's iodine which is a
solid solid right and solid normal yes
yeah it's normally a solid in my head
I'm like oh God did I get that order
wrong so um so it's very similar but it
just looks cool because it's like a
black scary looking liquid it does look
like an Elden ring boss it's about to
spawn out of it in all of your videos
but it's using kind of like just
specific chemistry reactions right
um it's used in organic synthesis but
it's like not that
okay you're basically giving bromine a
use of giving it all the heights yeah
purpose you're bringing the bromine hype
I've used it before to do a chemical
reaction it's just not I think it just
it looks cooler than yeah so use it on
it's visually very appealing yeah okay
because I just wanted to make it yeah
like this black scary liquid okay that's
fair enough
um yeah oh no go for it another question
I have is you say chemicals are
restricted right I I okay maybe this is
like a bad question to ask or maybe this
question was like don't ask that
question
what let's say there's a chemical that
is very prohibited but you can buy two
other scary chemicals that can make the
very scary band chemical what how does
that work are you like if you buy the
chemicals like you better not make this
with it well if you were if it's in the
US yeah like in the case for meth oh
they just
okay okay because meth is like the
probably one of the most well like the
one thing that people synthesize the
most like people also synthesize cocaine
and like all this other stuff it's just
that meth for whatever reason is like
the most well known that people make it
yeah for whatever reason well I'm just
saying like it's the most
like if I were to take people's make
like synthesized cocaine you're probably
like probably where's like it's kind of
a meme that people make math okay okay
but it's like what they did was it's
kind of for a long time it was like a
race between the sketchy camera I'll say
sketchy chemist and
um the government yeah so like At first
okay meth is illegal and guys like hey
well I got the ingredients for Math and
these are illegal so I'm just going to
make it I can buy these and I can make
it right right then the government goes
okay those chemicals are legal yeah the
guy's like well I have two chemicals can
that can make that chemical right so
they would just keep going down the
chain right and with meth it's gone so
far like it's like you're like sometimes
like I think it's like four things down
the line right and then you get you get
to the point where it's just like such
an obscure chemical that you can only
buy it from a chemical company right
because it's just like a petrochem like
made in Industry right there's almost no
way for you to just make it make it yeah
um and then you want to buy it from a
chemical company they will go like what
are you using it for and they'll write
your name down and they'll only let you
buy a certain amount right but there are
still ways around it of course like
there's still I mean I'm saying like the
illegal like the the
people who are six
people were synthesizing math
right yeah yeah to do it I mean yeah
obviously the fact that you know people
still making you know they well
sometimes they just go they just it
doesn't even matter that like four
chemicals down it's band yeah they just
illegally import either the meth itself
or are they just illegally import the
one ingredient lower one ingredient
right and a lot of it's from China I
think China would not to call them act
uh I think because they don't they would
just I I forget a friend who was
involved like he knew a lot about it he
didn't make it
that's such a funny sentence but you
know I know
it was a big thing on like Chinese
websites that they would make
I don't know what they would advertise
it as stuff like stuff that's very close
to drugs right but as something else and
then you could buy that but I I honestly
don't know too much is it like is it
like the herb Grinders and you know like
that kind of advertising well so like
it's not a bong it's a water pipe yeah
yeah well like one thing they would sell
like designer drugs for a while
so like straight up like almost
basically meth they would sell it for
like research purposes and you could
just buy it in the US because it wasn't
a scheduled drug I don't know all the
details about this but they would also
sell like the chemicals and stuff you
could find the sources and like I said
my sketchy days on eBay I didn't buy
anything like that but there was a guy
who's like
tell me what you want I can get you
anything
that's not what you want to hear that's
not what you want the stuff that was
just listed on eBay shouldn't have been
listed there all right what was like the
craziest stuff you saw listed on eBay it
was um hydrazine what's hydrazine it's
used for like rockets and stuff but it's
like if you see what they use like if
you look up hydrazine it just comes out
wrong people handling it are in like
full body suits because it's a very not
pleasant thing to deal with anything
about the FedEx guys kicking it around I
have a certain percentage it's like
really bad but so I think it's a I don't
know what if it's a gas or a liquid it's
pretty bad so you usually sell it as
like a 60 or something High
concentration in water yeah but the cow
just ship it in like an unmarked brown
box in like plastic bottles I never
bought it I actually regret I was like
I wish I did I wish I did because it's
hard like even though I can buy I can
order chemicals yeah I think what I
wanted to order hydrazine I had to go
through all these was it legal in Canada
to have the chemicals again there's no
laws
order it yeah well if you try to order
it from a chemical company they will ask
you like a lot of questions yeah ah look
what are you doing like specifically
like what are you using this for
um and so some things can be a big pain
to get have you ever had someone reject
you for chemicals where you've been like
hey I'm just making this one I've had
one company which they wouldn't they
would not let us have an account and
they wouldn't tell us why and we think
it's because they don't want their
products to be shown on camera but
you're not showing the products
endorsement I guess I I don't it's not
like you're saying here we have bro uh
bromium given by the the kind people
that chemical Corp they also might not
have liked it because I I kind of like
um let's show the anal Loop video maybe
yeah no I I just every time I use their
product in the past I'd always like shut
up negatively oh I think unfortunately
you would name the company yeah yeah
I said it because they're just
the big thing is these chemical
companies are really expensive oh I'm
sorry so it's like to give you an idea
there's one chemical I want to buy like
let's say 100 grams if you buy from them
it's like could be like 200 I bought it
on eBay for eight dollars but they
guarantee certain Purity the difference
is the eBay one I had to purify myself
[Music]
um but it's like they're worth buying
from they're just very expensive for a
lot of things so that's that's what I
would complain about okay okay you say
like I had to purify myself like this is
just like a thing that you just do yeah
I mean like it's just like a simple
thing to do right chemistry it's just
like I I think yeah it's like super
normal this is like the weirdest Rabbit
Hole I think
I think chemists podcasts scarier
scientists like they're the ones that I
am just scared of the most oh no I
believe this conversation they're just
terrifying like I don't because we just
don't know what the [ __ ] you guys are
doing yeah what chemistry because
because the thing is like you look at
like the sciences and like you know with
engineer you know you can like the a
normal person can kind of follow along
with what an engineer is doing what he's
building because you know it's a lot of
the times it's it serves a function you
know you can also like feel it and see
what's going on exactly yeah that's the
problem I don't understand what's
happening again yeah yeah when you name
a [ __ ] chemical I'm just like uh does
that burn your face off or does that
give you like a light tickle like I have
no idea what the [ __ ] you're handling
that's like the biggest challenge if I'm
going into chem is it's like a game
except there's so much knowledge you
need to just get started
um like organic I think that's like how
organic chemistry is right it's like
just it's just a game with the most
except you need to read what is it and
it's permanent it's like you have to
learn you have to study for like three
years just to like play it start playing